e
e e
yeah we'll give him some more time
good
morning call the fiscal committee
meeting to order of October 18th uh 2024
and I believe we're going to have the
governor join
us morning
Governor going to take some things out
of order as the the governor's uh
schedule we'll move to tab seven which
the governor wishes to
discuss Governor great well good morning
everybody always exciting to come to
fiscal kind of a rarity for me so I'm a
little nervous
you guys are more intimidating than CNN
no I'm just kidding I don't believe it
I'm just kidding so what um the and the
main reason I've I've chosen to come
here today is as I think most folks know
uh we're really at the end uh our the
clock has run out as I as I've said many
times in terms of the use of this arpa
money the federal it's a federal clock
it all has to be done really effectively
all these items any additional arpa
items through fiscal effectively have to
be approved uh today because there's an
executive councel process there's always
some hiccups with the agencies for this
and that making sure that we get all the
the federal eyes dotted and te's crossed
so um uh the the clock is really here
the main the other main reason I I
wanted to come directly is uh there has
been a a large amount of money that has
now been made available um unfortunately
for the wrong reasons um we the eight
items I'd like to talk about today uh
account for about about $
13.78 million now the source of the
funding is the $15 million arpa grant
that we had pre previously given I think
everyone was very excited to give uh to
solution Health uh this was boy going on
18 months to two years ago now the money
has very recently been returned when in
the very last minute decision the
londonairy Town Council voted against uh
an a memorandum of understanding that
would have allowed this critical new
mental health hospital to move forward I
think everyone was excited exced about
that um I don't mind saying I think it
was a completely foolish decision by the
town of London der it took us all by
surprise but be that as it may we have
$15 million return to us what I've we've
really tried to do is keep all $15
million in a single item uh for
efficiency sake but really to address
mental health I mean that was the
original purpose of the dollars um as
well as address some of the uh uh
concerns driven not just by uh the
fiscal committee but by the legislature
we tried to hear some of the requests
and and items that the legislature had
brought up that we pre previously didn't
have dollars for so we're just trying to
be as responsive as we can as quick as
we can uh to the needs before us so the
goal is to redirect as much of that $15
million back into mental health um the
reason we talked about was for more for
efficiency purposes
um I guess we can just kind of jump
right into them if if that's okay so
within this item uh what you see before
you on item a there's really three
aspects to item a and and I'll go
through them one at a time and of course
we can take questions so the first piece
of item a is a $2 million allocation to
Health and Human Services transitional
housing and this is to support the
establishment of an 8-bed therapeutic
transitional housing program for
individuals with mental health
conditions the program assists in that
the Department's bigger effort Around
Mission zero which as you know is really
to make sure that we don't have any
individuals waiting in our emergency
rooms or hospitals awaiting mental
let me interrupt you for a moment so to
for us to refer to the item looks like
it's uh
24371 thank you sure sorry about that we
give everyone a
minute everybody have it all right thank
you okay sorry about
that um
so this first item again is $2 million
for the transitional housing piece
supporting the Department's effort
Around Mission zero in the mental health
boarding crisis um what this really does
is create eight new beds to move folks
out of New Hampshire hospital uh to
facilities and uh programs that more fit
the level of care based on their current
needs there's a lot of folks just in New
Hampshire hospital unfortunately that
don't have a transitional place to go uh
New Hampshire hospital is really for the
most intense and and immediate acute
needs of mental health these folks don't
necessarily require that and so
Contracting with a an an organization
that currently uh does this kind of work
allows that transition moving eight
people out of eight more people out of
New Hampshire hospital freeing up those
eight beds for new incoming patients
with more acute
needs the second piece of item a is
approximately $3 million to renovate uh
the pych the psychiatric residential
treatment facility at Hamed hospital
that's the prtf that a lot of people
know it by uh the new design at this the
center of excellence which we have
already established it does not increase
the hospital footprint at all uh it will
be more open in the common areas provide
more single bedrooms that are
therapeutically necessary uh for certain
youth with very intensive uh
psychosocial needs and and complex
trauma and the item really addresses
calls from the community this was a big
part part of I think both the community
and the legislature we heard it loud and
clear we want to keep more kids in state
right if we can have these acute
specialization opportunities where we
don't have to send kids out of state uh
for for more of the intense rarer needs
around mental health that's that's a
better thing keep them close to home
this increases uh the bed count from 6
to 12 and upgrades the beds that we
currently have there uh bringing more
specialization in so that is is one that
I think is a great opportunity uh and
again just kind of responding to
everything everything that we've heard
and I think all of our desire is to keep
more of our kids closer to home in state
with more of those complex
needs item um the third aspect of item a
before you is approximately $2.7 million
um and that that actually uh finances a
variety of smaller um we call them a
kind of alternative bid items um which
were not included in the base bid of the
uh original YDC these are more YDC
driven items again responding to
legislative concerns we've heard
Community concerns we've heard how do we
increase security how do we reduce
Demand on Town Services these dollars
are all really directed in that effort
um it does everything there's a there's
a a variety of small uh pieces here but
it does everything from um you know
upgrade the doors uh to the system um uh
building out the crisis stabilization
unit right for those more intense
moments um if for kids that might be
within YDC so again we're just trying to
minimize the if you will the demand in
in the the push of kids to walk away
from that facility having more of those
opportunities within the facility keeps
it more secure and there's a couple
small pieces in here to retain you know
helping to retain staff areas where we
can train staff uh in different aspects
uh Lessons Learned type scenarios um
those types of build outs again if we're
retraining more staff we can again uh
have a better eye on the facility and
and reduce that Demand on the town of
Hamstead police State Police whatever it
might require um so it's all just
building out a much better experience
experience for those kids but more
importantly a more secure facility uh
for the town of
Hamstead uh item four uh so that's the
the bulk of really the that's about half
of the item and that's that's the bulk
of the kind of the mental health pieces
uh the most of the the remainder of
these items for this uh 13.78 million
are more legislative requests Less on
the mental health side of things um now
item four was
$685,000 uh for the Department of
Corrections this is a uh for a previous
project it's an ongoing project uh for
the repair of air handlers and duct work
over at the Men's prison um the base
project has been funded by this by this
group that was wonderful but due to um
inflationary cost and supply chain
issues they're looking for another
$685,000 so we're we're mostly done the
project we're looking to finish out uh
finish out the project at 685,000 uh a
few of the Reps and and state senators
had called us and asked to make sure
that that this project could get
done uh the department of Environmental
Services also looking uh this was
$500,000 dealing with a very public
issue we all hear about every day
cyanobacteria um to take a step back
Dees currently has we have fully funded
and this in the legislature has done a
great job fully funding the remediation
of cyanobacteria concerns that can be
remediated today so if there's
cyanobacteria in a lake and we can put
remediation to it it's this technical
Alum stuff you put in the water it
really encapsulates the cyanobacteria um
there de yeses I think has done a good
job um moving those projects forward the
reason we don't have more projects ready
to go is a lot of the smaller towns
don't have the funds to figure out how
bad the problem is so these going
through the Lakes Association they'll be
coordinating with towns and localities
other smaller Lake Associations um uh
Community associations to do those
studies to figure out is there
cyanobacteria issue how bad is it and
and what kind type of mitigation needs
to be done at that point down the road
obviously I think we all understand that
there may need to be additional funds to
mitigate that those issues if the
cyanobacteria persists but um the it's
it's a bit of an unknown especially for
a lot of these smaller communities and
this $500,000 will allow them to do
those
studies uh the department of admin
Services is uh uh has a 1.3 two two
requests one at $1.3 million um it's a
state house uh compliance issue with ADA
compliance obviously that's a
requirement it's a bathrooms issue we
have to make sure that we upgrade uh the
the public facilities uh that are to
make sure that they're ADA Compliant
there's another uh at Department of
administrative Services piece here for
2.4 million uh for this very building
for the um uh improvements to the State
House Annex Building Renovations
including electrical Mechanical plumbing
improvements and including some of the
removal of hazardous waste um items that
come and then finally uh to round out
this $ 13.78 million request um gopher
has a $1.4 million request uh
technically for to the county of
straford they have a roof a very
significant very severe roof leakage
problem uh that really has to be
addressed immediately um so when we
looked at some of the higher needs and
priorities this was one that um if not
funded I there's kind of a question of
where those funds might come from so
we're just looking to assist the
courthouse um which we've done before
but this is a little more of an
emergency need that rounds out the 13.78
million again is um kind of putting it
all together trying to be efficient get
these things done and allow the
executive Council because as we know the
the commission the Commissioners
themselves the agencies in the executive
Council um have their end of the process
as well so we can answer any questions
you can kick me out ask Taylor oh you
know I'm good at math that's about it
thank you Governor questions from
committee members representative Edwards
and representative blazel and thank you
Mr chairman and thank you governor for
considering my questions I I I'm I want
to get down into the weeds just a little
bit and uh I apologize for that I I
commissioner Weaver and Dr hen have done
a great job I think at opening up a
design review process where a bunch of
interested stakeholders could take a
look at exactly some of the details of
the new
YDC and um and so there were a few
things that I'd like to just make sure
that are in the public record that that
we're going to take care of one one is
um we want to have the Hamstead hospital
and the new YDC as an integrated
operation and there's a walkway that you
may not even know about that connects
the two buildings that are just wide
open to weather it was an additional
item um I think it's really going to be
important that we ensure that that
walkway gets to be covered and secure uh
in order to um move patients and people
and supplies back and forth between the
buildings in the winter and not have
problems and so so that's that's a big
one I'd like to make sure gets on there
the the other one is we've talked about
the trouble with integrating the
security of the operations between the
Hamstead hospital and the new YDC right
now it it feels like the infrastructure
is there for two different Security
offices and and because the it is uh
incompatible there's been some issues
about trying to integrate into a single
secure um Management Center and i' I'd
like to know if we're going to try to
resolve that in this initial buildout
because that would help with the
security issue and and then the the
third thing is um maybe doesn't have a
budget impact but it's about worrying
about whether or not drones may be able
to drop paraphernalia and other things
into the wreck wreck area there were
some technical options considered I just
would like an update on that so that we
could get those three things sort of
locked in on what our our intent is with
this money sure so I can I can address a
couple of them and I may have to ask the
the commissioner to come up uh I do
believe the walkway has not been
included the walkway was priced out at
just under $1 million for the walkway
that was expensive and I think it was
determined that um if there's another
way to do it obviously I I completely
agree with you I think it' be phenomenal
to have that but I think at a million
dollars for an enclosed walkway that
just didn't make the list of of you know
make the top priorities um including uh
as far as the Drone technology I don't
believe we've that that's I know it's
been talked about and looked at over at
the Men's prison and I I didn't realize
it was being talked about here I don't
know if you you have any information on
that sure good morning yes uh we are
working with admin services in DPW now
to explore no fly zones for things like
drones imagine that would include the
prison as well yeah
and then if I may a million dollars to
cover that walkway is probably $950,000
too much uh I I had the same gut
reaction to that and and and that's why
I've been so obsessive about getting
that walkway covered is because it just
seems to me like it's so obvious it has
to be done uh and the the money estimate
is just way out of bounds Beyond Common
Sense yeah I maybe there's an
opportunity to go out and and rebid that
piece I mean it's a walkway it doesn't
have to be done in conjunction with the
main construction obviously it would be
easier to do that um you know one idea
would be just to again we one thing
we've tried to we've di I want to
reemphasize something we're not adding
any new beds to IDC we're not changing
the footprint or anything like that I
guess you could always design ask the
the the contractor just to plan the
space I mean you could do a small
redesign if if a future walkway was
possible but right now at nearly a
million dollars the needs were more on
the beds and you know the care of the
kids and the secur and and the
additional security pieces that I know
the community was looking for so thank
you I didn't it's way in the weeds I'm
so sorry to bring it up good questions
and I and I would just if I may
definitely something to look at in the
future um you know depending on on the
demand there senator birdell for a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
governor for taking my question has
there been any consideration in um in
some of this money to reimburse uh the
town of Hamstead for all of the uh
emergency response work that they've
done over the past year Well I believe
that's taken up with the property the
the property tax uh allocation that was
made by the legislature
well and I thank you for um putting that
um having that passed but
191,000 doesn't really recoup a lot of
the money that was spent on the
emergency response I can get a number
from the um chief of police but um it's
probably cost a lot more than 191,000
the legislature can look at that this is
one-time money so I would say so we're
trying to keep the onetime arpa dollars
to onetime infrastructure construction
costs that would theoretically be an
ongoing cost and I my sense is as as the
facility opens up the long-term Demand
on both Hamstead and YDC because we
don't even have YDC up and running yet
um I think we'll be we'll be better
determined and obviously something for
the legislature to look at but we just
Tred to keep everything to onetime money
and and I I understand that my my
thought process is to recoup what
they've spent in the past because the
numbers of visits I believe has started
going down so it's not it's probably not
going to be an issue go as much going
forward but what they've spent in the
past is is what I'm I'm concerned about
yeah well I
I I would I would only say that I'm not
against doing that if it's a one time
cost other than today's kind of the day
like I don't have that data it sounds
like you don't have that that
information I don't think we've ever
been sent a bill or an invoice above the
property tax piece that that we are we
are granting which is a large amount of
money so that would probably require a
little more analysis in terms of what
that what that was thank you yeah
senator rosenal for a question thank you
and thank you governor for being here my
question really I think is for
commissioner Weaver
um we are all on board about having a
prtf and um bringing New Hampshire's
children back who don't quite need
Hospital level
care about two years
ago when the prtf was being constructed
we got a tour and we're told it was a 12
B
prtf so I guess my question is how is it
that the department was building a 12
bed unit and it turned out that it was
only a six-bed unit and now we have to
spend a lot more money to make it what
you were planning to
do sure um I think it's worth noting
this is the first PRT that New Hampshire
has so um first Venture into the space
it is actually there actually are 12
beds as we open the facility um and pro
provided care it became clear pretty
quickly that the space was limiting to
safely provide that clinical care for
the 12 so it kept the census lower which
is what the governor is referring to
around that six um so when we built that
out the time um through clinical
practice prce said we needed more square
footage as well as single bedrooms so
that became and I think the governor
mentioned that as well became critical
that we have uh a safe environment for
kids and that we can take more kids so
we know that by making the single
bedrooms by expanding that footprint
creating some life skill areas a larger
um space where they're not necessarily
as uh closer proximity will allow us to
take kids and be more successful and be
at that 12 rather than hovering between
that six and that eight so I think it's
you know as you open it up and as you go
these are things that you find out it's
an old building it's over 50 years old
and it really hasn't had any renovation
so we tried to make it work in the space
with the vendor that we had at the time
and this is the point we're at right now
um followup thank you but I but I know
that you have colleagues in other states
and belong to
associations
where you can gain from the expertise of
other states that have had
ptfs did the
department take advantage of
saying asking questions like or do
double rooms work how how many single
beds do we need or did we just go into
it
blind no I don't think we went into it
blind and we were we just had opened up
the hospital taking over the hospital
and then adding a brand new service line
with a new vendor at the time so we did
do a lot of research the vendor did a
lot of research at the time um and I
think through practice we found out that
the current foot we had is not uh
clinically safe and we want to expand
that so I think there's good sound
programming there I think it's the
infrastructure that needs to be matched
with that
programming or adjusted or edited if you
will edited yeah if I may add the just
to be clear the 12 beds meet the federal
guidelines and I think that's what we oh
well the guidelines say X Y and Z and
you can double up and all that but again
when you look I'm just speaking I don't
have the expertise of of the
commissioner but the high intensity
needs of some of these kids don't don't
really allow for a double bed situation
all the time or they don't have other
common areas or or open areas and that
that makes for a a tougher therapeutic
uh assessment and treatment of those
individuals um which again this is all
designed to make if the atmosphere and
the treatment and the the clinical
process is more fitting to those kids
you're going to have less of them trying
to get out if you will or walk away from
the facility uh or or act out in other
ways so yeah it all meets the federal
guidelines now I guess technically you
could you could pack 12 kids in there
you could but it's not going to be good
it's not going to meet the needs of
those kids um and ultimately this is all
about the care right getting the kids
the best care um and and making sure the
facility is safe and and the staff feel
safe and the staff feel like they can
actually do the treatment that they were
they were designed to do and I think I
mean we I I don't I think it's okay to
say I've personally spoken to mlan Great
institution in in um Massachusetts that
handles uh that these types of prtf uh
facilities beds the the high-intensive
and I they all concur that yeah federal
guidelines are one thing the
requirements are one thing but meeting
the needs of the kids to to get them the
best care and uh and limit the amount of
um of you know attempts of walking away
from a facility like that require some
editing editing
we'll use that word if I could I I don't
dispute any of that my question is just
Why why didn't
we take advantage of what people as
close as mlan could have told us two
years ago so we did it right the first
time that's all obviously we want to
treat the kids in the best way but I'm
just wondering why we didn't do a better
job planning it the first time thank
you senator birdell for a question just
quickly so if we didn't if we didn't
have this found money so to speak would
we still be looking to expand that
space yes I was going to be making a
capital budget request to do
so any other questions recognize Senator
gray I'm move uh FIS 24 371 found under
Tab 7 for approval second motion a
second further discussion on item 24
371 do we have to take it off the
consent calendar
first no no
okay we've already taken it off so
that's been
accomplished well
parlamentar okay that we have not taken
up the consent calendar yet so and
that's why when I read the uh motion to
approve it that I mentioned both the
number and the section Etc that would it
was in so that there would be no
confusion further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I iose no the item is
adopted thank you sir thank you
Governor thank you
all
right
okay we'll now uh go to our regular
calendar we'll welcome uh old
business Senator Senator Pearl replacing
uh Senator Bradley welcome Senator and
we'll start off with tab
one acceptance of the minutes some
Move Motion and a second to accept the
minutes is there any further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no that item is adopted and tab two we
have an item that was placed on the
table recognize Senator biril I move to
take item 24 320 off the table than
motion second to take the item off the
table further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I I oppose no
the wish to be
recorded all right two
NOS all right let's let's show a hands
how many in favor taking it off the
table all right and how many opposed two
three right 7 to three the item is off
the table open for discussion
Senator gray uh Senator Bradley
apparently is the one that took this uh
tabled this one uh his concerns have
been resolved uh it is a lot of money uh
but uh there is a need thank
you move to approve Senator birdell
moves to approve Senator gray seconds
for item
24320 further discussion Senator
dallesandro thank you very much much uh
Mr chairman uh I agree there are needs
but there are lots of needs mental
health has lots of needs we're running
mental health facilities at negatives
and we're treating people there with
very significant problems this is a
$500,000 item I have great empathy for
for the animals certainly uh but I have
more empathy for human beings who need
services and when I see that my mental
health Center is running in the negative
when I see the mental health center in
Conan is running at the negative and I
see $500,000 going of to a datable
shelter I say where are our
priorities my priorities my priority is
taking care of people that's what I ran
for that's what I've been here for for a
long period of Time That's
essential and we know the suicide rate
is high we know people living in the in
in the streets
because they can't take care of
themselves I mean we have basic
responsibilities as Citizens and as
elected
officials and I think this
$500,000 could be better
spent based on the needs that have
manifested themselves over and over
again we had a windfall of of money we
should use it as we see best to satisfy
the needs of people thank you Mr
chairman further
discussion representative
Edwards thank you Mr chair and if the
senator take a a question I because I
I'm moved by your argument um but I'd
just like to get some clarity on your
position are you aware of another
$500,000 one-time investment that we
should be making in the mental health
system or or were you talking about
using it for operational issues that
we'd have to have a funding tail for uh
thank you for the question make make
make sure that I understand the clarity
of it what what I'm saying is we have
had requests from mental health centers
for money they and we gave them money we
gave them
500,000 that didn't satisfy all of their
need but it was what was available at
the time another 500,000 now has become
available it seems to me that we should
address needs that we couldn't address
fully at the time because we didn't have
the money now we have more money because
of the windfall that has been created by
the return of the 15 billion dollar from
Solutions health because they're not
building the they not building the
building I think the direction of this
500,000 should be to address that
situation that we could only partially
address in the passed I hope that's the
answer your
question representative
lean thank you Mr chairman is it
possible we could have the commissioner
come up and explain why he supports this
request
yes is the commissioner
available thank
you question was sorry Taylor cwell
I guess I was just curious uh you made
the request and maybe you could justify
the request for us so this is a request
that we have um had ongoing for quite
some time uh from the Manchester Animal
Shelter uh if we go back to uh I believe
even uh late Caris or early arpa there
was a request for uh funding for animal
shelters generally um we did do an
analysis at that time which indicated
that um you know there wasn't
necessarily a need for operational uh
costs um uh to be provided to uh animal
shelters across the state and so that
one did not come to you at the time uh
since then we have had a subsequent
request from the Manchester Animal
Shelter initially for an amount of $2.5
million for a complete re um rehab of
their
facility um we did determined that we
wouldn't be able to be provide the full
$2.5
million uh for that fac so we push we we
we put forward the request for a request
for $500,000 and that's sort of how it
got to you
today for for my own opinion we we
thought this would be onetime money we
should spend it on onetime events
obviously mental health continues on
forever and I believe there are some
other items in here that assist the uh
within this agenda that assist mental
health so we've got it we've got these
needs from all over but one time onetime
events should possibly take precedent on
some of these monies because they won't
be coming back repeatedly for another
building so that's the way I looked at
it Senator Rosenwald then Senator B
thank you if I could respond to
representative edwards's question as
well I think both
the Community Mental Health Centers and
the federally qualified Health Centers
both had
onetime funding gaps because of the
Medicaid
unwind where a significant number of
people lost eligibility
for
insurance however their care
continued either those people now have
rejoined Medicaid or have found some
other insurance or in some case they
aged out of Medicaid but to me those are
onetime funds because the unwind is
complete so I agree with my colleague
Senator
dandro that um our Mental Health crisis
and also the federally qualified Health
Centers they got very small Medicaid
rate increases so I think one-time
infusions of this money could be
incredibly helpful for the people of New
Hampshire thank you Senator bir shall
then Senator agree I would just I mean I
don't disagree what with what my
colleagues have said however we just
authorized over $2 million to Hamstead
hospital to help with the U mental
health of our our kids um and we have
spent a lot of money in our budget and
we will continue to spend a lot of money
in our budget on the mental health of
our our our residents so um
$500,000 I think um for this for
Manchester Animal Shelter I think is not
unreasonable and I'm going to go ahead
and support
it Senator gray um if you take any of
the individual items that we've
processed throughout these past
months one or two May stand out to you
okay but if you look back to the
philosophy that the the budget that we
just passed for the
state everybody got a little bit
everybody got a little bit and that's
how we were able to pass it through the
Senate and that's how we were able to
pass it through the house we are taking
one small item
in the millions and millions of dollars
that we've done here and putting a
microscope on it as I said at the
beginning of this when we right after we
pulled it off the table it is a lot of
money and as the commissioner said we've
taken the request from 2.5 and given
them a fifth of
it is it the right thing to
do well again if we are looking at
saying
this group deserves
something this group deserves something
which is like I said the philosophy that
was used when we created the budget that
we are living under right now this fits
in this is one of those items that ought
to get their little piece and that's why
I will support the
item Senator Pearl thank you
commissioner you you said you had a $25
million do request originally and one
one of the concerns I always have and
perhaps you can address this for me is
when we take and partially fund any
request is that the money we're giving
them they'll be able to actually do good
things with it were you able to identify
that this half a million dollars would
be able to cover some of the real high
priority projects of the two and a half
million they originally
requested yes Senator we did do U an
analysis of their capability to uh
complete the project because we don't
just have the obligation deadline that
is the subject of a lot of the
discussion today we have the full
expenditure deadline which is uh
December 31st 2026 so we don't bring
anything forward to you that we don't
think they going to have the potential
to complete within that time frame thank
you representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair and uh thank you Mr
commissioner I so what I think I've I've
heard is that um this this onetime money
is being set up to be used for long-term
ongoing infrastructure at the animal
shelter and that while there may be
other operational ways to spend the
money in mental health we don't have an
identified
unfunded
infrastructure alternative in the mental
health area that's competing with this
animal shelter infrastructure I it just
came from Rome they built things for
3,000 years I I want to know that this
money is going to go to building
something that's going to be sustainable
for many many years in the future and
not a one-time expense can is C could
you just clarify was there a
competing
infrastructure project for a half a
million
dollars um I would say um representative
we have a lot of requests that have come
in um I wouldn't be able to say
definitively that there isn't a match
for this particular amount of money for
a amount of requests that we've had from
other in other categories
um um so I I'm not sure that I could
definitely say to you if not this it
would there would be nowhere else to
spend it I I I wouldn't be able to say
that Senator gray I moved to approve the
item fis2 for 320 already did it's
already been done done all right we did
that already clerk will call the role on
the vote of octop pass on FIS
24320 representative
Edwards
yes yes representative lean
yes thank you representative wner
yes Senator gray yes Senator Pearl yes
Senator bdel yes Senator
Rosenwald
no Senator delandro no Senator wer
representative representative
wer
sorry the vote is seven to three in
favor chairman the item passes
okay moving on to uh tab three through 8
that's the consent
calendar uh 30 there's 35 items now on
there and plus late items that I will
come to later
so these are the items that I've had
requests to
remove under Tab
4 243
24362 and under Tab 5
24358 under tab
six 24343
and under tab
seven
24353 and
3 72 we have already passed item
24371 so that is not included now in the
consent calendar Senator Gray
move to approve second motion to approve
the rest of the items on the consent
calendar by Senator gray second by
Senator bird cell further
discussion guess we've got all the items
that are going to be removed all in
favor of the items of adopting the
remaining items say I I oppose
no remaining items are adopted so we'll
move on to Tab four item 335
and I
believe it was was that representative
Edwards had a question on
that uh I don't believe that was my
question I my note said uh
representative for the Senate oh I think
that was the Senate Senator
rosenal I did have a question but I
don't know if house members also did all
right Health and Human Services is here
the question is on FIS
24335 Department of Health and Human
Services Division of economic stability
thank
you good morning Karen heaper division
director for economic
stability Nathan white Chief Financial
Officer thank you Senator rosenal has
recognized for a question thank you very
much Mr chairman so um this was part of
s Bill
499 um which was for summer EBT benefits
the bill was passed on June
13 and um for some reason did not get
signed until August 2nd making us miss
the entire summer so the
$150 that you're proposing is going to
go on the November EVT cards
do we expect that that is going to still
be there next
summer I mean I just I don't understand
the timing of this because it was for
summer food
benefits thank you very much senator for
your question and concern I this is a
program that was newly established by
the US Department of Agriculture uh and
the rules and guidance for this program
did not not get released until December
and then into January and February the
federal government was very aware of the
late start of establishing this to issue
a summer of 2024 benefit so the states
have been working very closely with the
federal government to get the benefit
distributed as soon as it possibly can
but it has always been known uh from the
beginning uh of the calendar year that
we would Target and uh to get the
benefit issued in November and into
December it has always been planned that
way um and we have uh uh certainly
spoken about it a number of times uh in
different forums about that plan the
federal government also did not approve
the state's plan for the summer of 2024
benefit until August
16th so despite that we do want this to
be a summer
related benefit it has always been known
that we would not be able to implement
the distribution until the fall which we
are doing the intent is to be able to uh
have this program in place so long as
the federal government approves the
state's plan uh year after year and that
the funding exists as well so that the
benefit could be issued prior to the
beginning of the summer op what's known
as a summer operating period period
which would start uh as soon as classes
uh end in that current school year and
it would last through the period of time
when classes resume in that following
school year period uh so that that is
the intent but as I as I mentioned it
certainly has been um a challenge to be
able to get the funding uh distributed
as close to summer as we
can follow up thank you you so because
it the legislative intent was for a
summer EBT program and it's
$150 which I mean I go grocery shopping
so I know that I know it doesn't go that
far did the department give
consideration towards holding off for
next summer so that school children who
didn't necessarily really have access to
nutritious food during the summer would
have this
$150 benefit next
summer so it's an annual benefit uh so
that would happen regardless of what we
did with a summer of 24 benefit the
intent is to have a summer benefit each
summer
so from what you're what you're saying
that even though that we missed the boat
here or somebody missed the boat here
it's a recurring program and it will now
be in the
summer yes the the plan uh and according
to requirements for the program we would
be issuing the
benefit just before the beginning of the
summer operating period because the
intent is to have this benefit available
when school is not in session uh so that
that's that's the the target to be able
to implement this before the summer
operating period but the because of the
late start of the entire program with
the federal government we weren't able
to do that for summer of
24 so we missed it we missed it one time
but in the future we've got it
covered so long as the federal
government approved proves the state
plan every year and that the funding is
available yes sir okay so we have no
guarantee that this is an ongoing
program for a number of years it's just
every year you have to apply for this
that is correct it would seem to make
more sense to hold this money for next
summer I think we'd all support that
rather than having it spent now and then
an expectation next fall to have the
same money again rather than spending it
now and and when all the meals are going
to be provided out of school anyway so
representative
Edwards thank you division 3 spent quite
a bit of time on SP 499 that Senator
Rosenwald mentioned and we amended that
bill and left the summer EBT portion in
it um we at the time and and this is one
of the details I want to clarify this
$5.6 million this is for the two fiscal
years and not just the first fiscal year
that because that's the amount of money
we thought the total 2-year program
would be that there would be 2 months in
24 July and August and that there'd be
the full three months in the following
year the biggest criticism of this
program when division 3 spent a lot of
time on it was that it's labeled a
summer EBT program but we knew that the
program wasn't going to be able to get
established until there was a
retroactive payment in in around
Halloween so so we knew that we the kids
weren't going to get the money in the
summer but they the family would catch
up around Halloween so so
I so I I I kind of I support that intent
because that's that's what we try to do
I I just want to make sure that this is
not just 24 money this is 24 and 25
money so this award is specifically the
benefit funds for the summer of
2024 and it needs to be expended uh
before the end of the calendar year of
24 we will or we
anticipate a separate award specifically
for the summer of
2025 uh which we would bring back before
you the okay maybe I'm getting confused
that there were the general funds got
that there's a combination of state and
federal money in here and the and that
what we're talking about is the total of
both sure um so so ju just to clarify a
couple of things SP 499 did have a
number of general fund Appropriations
and if you look at the Appropriations
within the bill you'll see that there
were two positions established there as
well as the funding that was needed to
make the system changes those were the
general fund costs that were required
the dollars that you see here this is
the federal award for the summer of 2024
benefits and you'll see also that we are
creating a new account here so in the
next budget cycle um I I would expect a
change request at some point once we
have better information on what we would
expect these Federal benefits to be but
these dollars here are explicitly for
the benefits to be paid out for 2024
alone and then those other general fund
dollars that representative Edwards was
referencing was to help stand up the
program and you'll see in the grant
award documentation that's provided to
you the award wasn't provided until
August 16th of this year which again is
sort of why and at for the many
challenges that that Karen uh
articulated why we're coming here now
and why the payments will be made
through
November follow thank you for refreshing
my memory Mr White I I and and it's
clear that this is 100% the Federal
component and we were willing to spend
General funds to get us set up so that
we would be eligible for this and it had
a nice payback it was about 79% or
something so so I I intend to vote in
favor of this U because I I think it's
completely consistent with what our
intent was U as it came out of the
house representa Senator rosenal thank
you um is the
department planning to put this program
in its efficiency budget or will it be a
prioritized need the Department's agency
budget has already been submitted that
was due back in August and because we
did not yet have a specific account
established for this we we did not
include that until we came through
fiscal to accept those funds uh during
the budget process um I I I do expect
that we will be making a request to
incorporate these funds into the budget
process and into the new account that
has been established but due to system
limitations the account didn't exist so
we couldn't put it in there thank
you I don't believe we have a motion to
approve and I would make that at this
point
second okay Senator gray moves to
adopt Senator birdell seconds is there
any further
discussion I am not in favor of putting
money out that was supposed to be for
summer when wasn't meals to into the
fall when there are meals and so there
there'll be an expectation in the
proceed in the consuing Years well I got
it last year why don't I have it this
year and I think it's a dangerous thing
to do any further
discussion seeing none all in favor of
this say I I oppose no
no moving on to the next item off of
consent
would be item 339
24339 and who has a question on this
one this was a senate office this was I
think this was a senate request for
removal um all of the items on this page
that you've put on uh pulled uh I had no
notes on them being pulled by a senator
so representative Wier if I may um you
did just have a question in House pref
fiscal relative to the definition of
foreign organization foreign that was my
that was my question that's an exhibit a
of of their submission there's a very
lengthy
um exhibits added to this item some of
them raised my my caution when we're
talking about foreign governments and
and foreign languages and all this kind
of thing I'm suspicious of what I've
seen in some in some states of
taking immigrants whether they're legal
or illegal and making them police
officers is there any thought is is that
included in this
item uh thank you for the question uh Mr
chairman good morning morning my name is
John skip I'm the director of police
standards and training uh presently uh
through administrative rule uh one of
the requirements to be a police officer
in the state of New Hampshire is to be a
United States
citizen uh and there is no other uh
waiver or any other pathway to become a
police officer in this state uh under
the administrative rules do you know why
the stuff was included in here about
foreign governments and so on it is our
understanding sir that that is um a
boilerplate uh template language that is
used by the Department of Justice when
we secure these uh these grants thank
you any further discussion move to
approve second motion to approve by
Senator birdell second by Senator gray
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say I I I the item is adopted
thank you thank
you okay the next item would be 340
and this is similar to 350 dealing with
the security at the New Hampshire
hospital representative lean has a
question thank you Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question uh it's noted
here that a request for proposals went
out on March 27th have you received
anything back or is that still out there
waiting for proposals yes thank you for
the question for the record Steve Lavoy
assistant commissioner of the Department
of Safety um we have received proposals
um I can share with you what we can
share publicly during the process we
have four proposals that were received
um we're working through a contract
process now which will go to GNC which
we're expecting to be at the end of this
calendar year okay thanks thank you Mr
chairman any further discussion move the
item motion to accept the item from
representative Lehman second by senator
dandro any further discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I oppose no the
item is adopted moving on to item
356 which is Department of Health and
Human Services representative Edwards is
recognize for a question uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr White uh so I
I my my my question about this given
that this is is is federal money is just
more related to
uh whether or not we have developed any
sort of metrics to understand whether or
not the money that we're spending the
federal money we're spending uh actually
accomplishes what we want to accomplish
in in this says the funds will support
Direct Services to New Hampshire
families promoting maternal and child
health positive parent child interaction
and developmental screening all great
things I just am looking for the
analytical part of this to say What
metric are we going to use to know
whether or not we're achieving the the
aims and goals of this uh new
spend sure thank you for the question uh
Ian wat I'm the director for the
division of Public Health Services so
the the home visiting program uses
something called the healthy uh family
America's evidence-based model uh which
speaks to exactly the the kind of
metrics you're you're looking to
determine representative Edwards so
things like number of families that are
are not entering um a child welfare
system do not have an open case with DCF
so we are we are trying to make sure
that families receive referrals to
services and care so they're developing
healthy habits healthy habits as a
family healthy parenting and and School
Readiness uh all those metrics are
things that I can pull from uh our
program in terms of numbers of families
uh in the program and positive uh
statistics as people no longer being
referred into those those Services thank
you Mr chair I just wanted to make sure
that we're we're measuring what we're
spending money to chase that that's my
main issue good good good management so
thank you for the
answer I I'd be willing to move the item
I'll
second okay motion to approve item
24356 by representative Edwards second
by Senator bdel Senator gr did you have
a
question any further discussion seeing
none are you ready for the are you ready
for the question all in favor say I I
oppose no the item is adopted moving on
to item
362 so that was me as
well representative Edwards had a
question so this is going to sound like
groundhog D it's the same issue I just
want to make sure that there are metrics
in place Hi how are you uh the the goal
of this spend is to uh provide Adult
Protective Services with resources to
enhance improve expand the ability of
APs to investigate allegations of abuse
neglect and exploitation all great
honorable worthwhile goals I just want
to make sure that we have a method for
management to evaluate whether or not
the spending is effective in
accomplishing those High aims thank you
for the question Melissa Hardy um
division director for long-term supports
and services to your point um this
funding is going to be used for a
quality improvement specialist which has
guidelines through um our federal
Partners as to how to measure quality
and APS Services so we will be following
um guidance from the federal government
and along with you know developing
structured work plans um and
improvements measures as for this
quality
position thank you Mr chair that
satisfies my question I'd be willing to
move if there not other questions second
motion and a second to approve item
362 is there any further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no 24362 is adopted we're moving on to
tab five and looking at item
24358 and this dealt with Medicaid to
schools
representative Edwards had a
question uh thank thank you uh Mr chair
I I
um my my question um about this is
really
um I as I as I came to understand this
program uh my initial concerns about
parental rights being protected were
were addressed a year or two ago when we
were more in a pilot phase and now we're
building the program out and I just want
to make sure that um we have assurances
that parents are going to uh firmly be
in a consent role for the services
provided and that they will in all cases
be entitled to receive the information
regarding their students care through
the program uh regardless of any sort of
HIPPA concerns or any other concerns or
are are we are we protecting the parents
ability to parent uh as we build out the
Medicaid for schools
program I think the short answer is yes
if I can just explain I think how um in
order to participate in this program you
have to be Medicaid enrolled uh a minor
cannot enroll themselves so they have to
have the parent enrolled in Medicaid um
secondly with respect to the service
Services the services are to support IEP
plans the individual education plan for
a child that has a disability or a 504
plan which is um for a medical condition
um and so to be able to participate in
learning right that's supposed to
support that both those plans require um
the the parents consent they also um
typically are developed in consultation
with the um the provider that is um the
associated with the child um then um in
addition with respect
to before they can even provide a
service there has to be consent that um
the service can be built to
Medicaid um a case head which would be a
parent in this case also um has a right
uh to obtain um the the billing
information but you know I think what
we're really talking about here is I
think if if uh someone's faithful to
what their responsibilities are both at
the school level parental level there
should be no issue here um and I think
what your concern is probably more in
the space of outside of the Medicaid
schools program because in the Medicaid
to school program the school itself has
to come up with effectively half the
cost of of the services so you know
someone who might access a program from
a school that uh isn't part of the
Medicaid to schools program which is
focused on supporting the IEPs and the
504 plans that that that is that could
have that exposure that you're concerned
about but um you know I think from an
ethical standpoint um you know the the
Medicaid schools program and how it's
structured I think has good protections
for parents and as I said if a you know
a parent um who's a case head is
entitled to if they ask the Medicaid
Program to provide what billing records
there are we're we're obligated to
provide those
thank you for that I I um i' I've heard
you even before the hearing explain that
to me and I'm I'm still just generally
concerned about this program uh
diverting the attention of the education
system into the provision of clinical
care and I'm concerned that if we don't
make sure that the parents remain in
charge of their students care completely
that we will create a trust issue that
will do long-term damage to the
educational the faith we have in the
educational system so so I'm worried
about over the long run the distraction
that this program may have on
maintaining academic Excellence focus
and and rather than belabor that I I
think we're scheduled for an HHS
oversight to do a deep dive on this and
uh and maybe we could take some of the
answers there to too I I spent as much
time with you on it I think though the
one point I want to make sure the
committee understands is that the the
Medicaid schools program when we're
talking about IEP plans you're talking
about children with disabilities where
the parent is trying to advocate in the
school to get services for their child
so they can learn or in the 504 plan the
child has a medical condition where
maybe they need a medication during the
day um that they need the school nurse
to to to administer um so I think it's a
little bit different but I think you
know happy to spend more time on that
you know the the CH what's involved in
this particular request is it's a
fundamental change in how schools are
going to get their funding and I'm
concerned about the the on-ramp that we
have to make the change the way that
we're doing it today in terms of
claiming the federal share is going to
be a very big change and schools need a
good onramp to to be able to to do that
we need um as the the grant has a
position to support that where we've got
a very we got to get to 174 different
School uh districts leas as they're
called under this
program you know may sound like June 26
is far away it's it's really not in
terms of by the time we finish the
procurement process for a vendor to
supply the software to do the the cost
reports and um the time studies and for
us to educate and and do everything I'm
feeling a lot of pressure with respect
to making sure that communities don't
end up
not being able to get funding which will
mean you know pressure on local
municipalities in terms of the cost of
uh supporting a service that they
required under uh law to
provide further so so thank you for all
that I'm I'm I'm I'm prone to support
this because this is obviously an in
incremental request to change the method
for how we you know Bill and get money
so so that all makes sense I'm just
concerned that as we take these little
steps that if we're off a little bit
then in the long run we may end up
somewhere we don't want to be and I want
at each step of this to be looking at
where we really ultimately want to go
and if the parents do not have faith in
this program um then that then then that
will keep this from being sustainable I
think and undermine the faith people
need in the education system as well so
so thank you for all of that and I I
look forward to ongoing cont
conversations thank
you motion by Senator dallis Sandra to
approve item 358 second by Senator
birdell is there any further discussion
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say I I oppose no item
24358 is adopted we'll move on to tab
six and item 20 24343
representative Earth is recognized for a
question uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here so I guess I'm not
very good at phrasing questions when I
write them so I'm going to try for the
third time on a couple of these there's
basically two questions I had left on
this and most of them were answered very
effectively thank you very much um the
easy one I hope is of the7
properties that were inspected related
to the lead levels in 2023 how many were
were found to have accessive levels of
Le thank you for the question so I would
need to uh consult with the team I don't
have those numbers in front of me uh if
we're going to a property uh which is a
result again of as noted the the
statutory requirement that we inspect a
property if a child uh under five tests
above the lead Action level um we would
have those results internally I would I
would have to talk with the team in
terms of what is publicly available some
of the information is very identifiable
so I'll have to work with the team of
what information we can share okay well
I would certainly hope that providing a
number where it was exceeded would have
nothing to do with any individuals or
certainly anybody else and that was
really the point I was trying to get
across this had to do with the ex x-ray
fluorescent devices that you acquired
some time ago um for this purpose and I
just kind of like represent of Edwards
would like to see the the results of the
when you're spending these monies um
what are you achieving so I like to you
get information and then the other
question which I don't know how I how
this one didn't come across but it
didn't as I understand it this pot of
money that started being allocated way
back a couple years ago three years ago
maybe um about $22 million I'm not
mistaken originally has about $4.4
million remaining and I'm trying to and
I think if I understand correctly it has
to be expended by the end of this year
but in any case what I was trying to
understand is is it going to be spent
and if so on what thank you for the
question so the the original Grant uh
was awarded in 20121 and the conclusion
date was uh May 31st of this year 2024
we received earlier this year uh a
two-year extension so the funding is
actually extended uh at a grant level
through uh febu or sorry May 31st of
2026 uh and we did request an extension
for those two years uh we only request
extension for one project and that's the
community health workers uh that are
funded through contracts with our
federally qualified Health Centers
public health networks and the Family
Resource Centers we have uh about 30 of
those individuals funded uh $2 and5
million of the the 4.4 that you cited is
in contract uh and then we would seek to
use the additional uh money that's
available through of that 4.4 uh through
through that through those chws follow I
guess I must have misread this I thought
that part the turn just referred to or
actually I'm not referring to the money
but the people I thought the statement
was they were then moving over to a
different program and being funded over
there so so the individual so sorry let
me let me separate two points this item
specifically is to extend a single state
position a program planner three that
individual is no longer funded by the
health disparities Grant the the reason
that item is before you is that we had
uh an administrative question in terms
of the extension of the position it is
now funded through a a Federal grant for
chronic disease um so it's not the 22
million uh is not material to that
position anymore it's funded through a
chronic disease Grant uh that's a legacy
Grant we have in public health that has
a I don't have the end date in front of
me um the 22 million has no State
positions associated with it at this
point that four and a half million or
$4.4 million is all being used for
contractual costs for the 30 community
health workers that are employed at
contracted
agencies okay can you just repeat that
what you said about the so the two and a
half million who you you didn't even
name what that was for what did you what
was the name you used so those are for
community health workers uh and that's
contract work done through our FC's uh
Family Resource Centers and the public
health network so those entities uh with
whom we have contracts would then employ
the community health workers directly
thank you very much move the item okay
motion to move the item who was the
second rep representative Edwards move
FIS 24343 any further discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I the item is
adopted we'll move on to tab
seven and we'll look at item
353 Senator
birdell this is YDC
um sorry I did pull it off but I just
wanted to pull it off um because I I had
some I have some concerns about the um
payment to the YDC as as you know and
Nathan this has nothing to do with you
or the department but um the whole
process of how the YDC came to Hamstead
it to me has been a a completely flawed
um concept and I'm going to be voting
against the
numbers thank you Senator Pearl thank
you good morning thanks for coming in so
as I'm looking through this and reading
it I mean I I see you're asking for $5
million and and this is a I guess my
question is is this a problem that we're
going to have to solve and with general
fund monies next year if we do not solve
this with uh non- New Hampshire tax
revenue Now using the arpa funds sure
sure so the the purpose of this item
um
yeah I guess it was a good
[Laughter]
question that's it I so uh Charlie
Arling house I'm the commissioner of
administrative services and the uh this
money would support the construction
costs and the bid well let me let me
start small and then and then you can
follow up with it the bids came in high
this money would pay for the pay for the
construction if you if we don't spend
the money like let's say you killed this
item which I'm not
suggesting um but if you killed this
item then we can't go forward with a
contract um for the item we would have
to renegotiate a contract and do
something else and so um in terms of
solving it with General funds um no like
you couldn't say no and then later
appropriate General funds you have to
change other laws this is to support the
construction of the
facility
Well yeah so if if we don't approve this
it's going to it's going to put the
contract in Jeopardy or the project and
Jeopardy that you're trying to do now
but I guess yeah no if s or buts yeah
and wouldn't I mean isn't it reasonable
to think that at some point we're going
to have to do some type of upgrade with
general fund money later on to try and
Achieve what you're trying with this
project now well yeah because we have to
we have to have a facility and if you
don't use arpa funds for it you would
absolutely have to use General funds
yeah thank you I guess that was my my
real
question I I I I think one important
consideration is there's a provision
from hb2 this past cycle that prohibits
use of General funds for this
construction so if we don't use arpa
funds we don't have another source
within our budget today that we could
use given the constraints of state law
Senator rosenal thank you Mr chairman so
as I count up all of the money from what
we appropriated already what we approved
previously in fiscal what we did earlier
this morning and what we're being asked
for now it looks like this new facility
is going to cost about 37 million
and
um the
legislation that we
enacted to build a new
facility was for a census of 12 children
with a temporary surge capacity of no
more than 18 and so I just want to make
sure on the public record that we are
not nobody is planning to ever have more
than 18 kids and I have to say also I am
hoping when I see the Department's
budget that you're going to be budgeting
for a census of
12 and so that's kind of a two point let
me start with a construction standpoint
we we're building a facility and and
week if this item were to pass we expect
to go to um governor and councel as soon
as humanly possible with a contract with
huter who was the winning bidder um and
the facility we're we're building will
not support uh more than flexing to 18
it we are not building a facility where
it's it's even possible to do that so
from a from a construction standpoint if
you wanted to put more than 18 people on
the site ever you would have to uh uh
approach more dollars to do so which I
know nobody actually wants to do I can't
speak to the operating
budget and and and just to clarify it's
it's approximately 35.8 62 million total
um when when you will see our agency
budget request we are planning for a
transition during State fiscal year 27
so most of the operating costs that are
incurred today to operate the facility
will continue to be incurred because
that's the time period that last year is
a time period at which we're going to be
moving um there is a team that has been
working for probably eight maybe 10
months or more on that transition to
plan for that and so I'm I'm hoping as
we approach the spring particularly
during the Senate phase uh that we can
have further conversations and we'll
have additional refinements to that
original request and we can work with
you to to uh get the appropriate amount
the for the
facility representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair
um and this this is kind of for the
commissioner and commissioner earling
house as well um when when we started
really looking at the the um the
replacement of the cunu center uh there
were uh two two major schools of thought
you know one was that we needed to
evolve into the therapeutic care uh
approach to managing these juveniles at
risk and but the other was the enormous
uh annual operational cost of the sonunu
center and so what that drove us to was
a vision in the legislature I think of
of of saying that um this really needed
to be a shared uh resource operation and
that's why I think Hamstead got weighted
so well was that by collocation with
Hamstead we would be able to share the
all the resources the the the personnel
the logistics base uh and those sorts of
things and that sharing concept was
Central to the cost management of the of
the year-over-year
operations I hate to obsess on this
covered walkway issue but it's not just
a covered sidewalk it it it is the the
central element that creates a shared
operation if if you have to go outside
and the snow and the rain and and all of
that it it isn't a shared operation it's
two distinct operations and we're never
going to get the synergies we were
hoping for for the resources and and
even God forbid it is a million dollars
extra over the cumulative effect of the
operational impact that that that would
have I I just really would hope that the
managers of this project look at that
Corridor connecting the two facilities
as more than a covered walkway it it is
at its core the artery that connects and
allows the sharing of these resources
and and I I've just been frustrated over
the last 18 months that this shared
concept is is getting knocked off a
center because we can't build a a
corridor that's appropriate to the
sharing concept and so that there
there's really not a question there but
but Madame commissioner if you if you
would respond to
that so I just want to clarify on the
shared services Personnel wasn't
necessarily one of those shared services
we knew that food and laundry
Environmental Services um would be the
the centralized in trying to save and
efficiencies on that I don't disagree
with you about it being the artery I
think you knowing being part of some of
the design conversations there was a lot
of discussion about what was going to be
the most efficient and safe place to
actually place the facility to maximize
the proximity to the existing hospital
so that we weren't having I mean we
started out thinking about underground
right we were're going to be able to do
that obviously that was cost prohibitive
so we ended up with a walkway I I don't
disagree with you that it needs to be
covered I think just as a point it's
reasonable to think that as we go
forward and I share the conc ER to you
and your friend who testified earlier
that um a million dollars is kind of
High um and I think that there are a lot
of things that that that we can look at
as a state and and as as facility
managers um in terms of what we can do
with own forces and like there's a lot
of things for the for the for the YDC DC
itself that you can't do with own forces
but there are a lot of things like
related to walkways Etc that you that
you really can do and probably a lot
cheaper than a than a than a
construction bid and we've done that in
other other places where there are
things that end up being very pricey in
a bid because that's how bids often are
because they look at it as part of a
whole giant construction piece and then
you look at it and you're like you know
what we could do the carpeting in the
you know I picked that randomly but
little things like that we could pave
the parking lot we could help build a
covered walkway Etc so I'm sure
everybody's on board with that all right
thank you Mr chair I appreciate
everyone's patience as I obsess on this
covered corridor
Senator
birdell thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my uh question it's going to be
kind of a twofold But to answer um
representative Edwards I did have a
conversation with Justin lucer loose
loer um uh this week and they are also
very concerned about the walkway however
they are looking at various options
including um uh a van type of truck that
will allow um the transportation of
laundry and food service so that they
don't have to use the walkway so they're
looking at different options for the um
but the thing that I'm I'm concerned
about so
the the amount of construction that
we're looking at um is this just for a
shell and then do are they going to be
adding on um for the the projects the
different projects on the um on the
YDC the the building um right um uh is
this 35 million or the 21 is that just
for the shell of the building to build
and then are they going to do ad hoc um
no no it's a good question um the
Construction contract will will end up
being the the portion with the
construction company something like 32.4
million and and in doing so that's to
build a building um it it the while the
bid was constructed with with 15
alternates which of which we took I
think 10 and more or nine and one's a
one's a deduct alternate um you can see
um but uh it's the decisions were made
about alternates about things like the
covered walkway doesn't affect the I'm
sorry I shouldn't I shouldn't go here
but um the covered walkway doesn't
affect the operation of the building
that kind of thing would have been
looked at or or some things in parking
lots for example
but in terms of constructing the
building one of the things we we can't
go forward with a contract that does not
construct a building that can be used
and and this is a this is we are
constructing a functional building
period this isn't this isn't I'm going
to come back next year and go well we
need 10 million cuz um this is a
Construction contract a real honest to
God done in the middle of
2026 building my second question if I'm
allowed um in resp respons to
representative Edward he talked about
the shared services um was the laundry
the pharmacy um facilities and
food was that given a
greater were those Services given a
greater uh percentage Point versus the
closest hospital the state police
barracks and public transportation
because that is the biggest issue that I
have with the YDC coming into h dead we
have no nearby hospital the state police
are 30 m 30 minutes away and public
transportation is
non-existent anything
further is there an
answer yes I think they were all
considered as part of the criteria I
don't think that one was more than the
other they were all listed and weighed
out is what I understand from the
evaluation that we
did thank
you Senate agree move to approve second
Senator gray moves to approve the item
Senate appr seconds item 24353 is there
further discussion
approve I got one from representative
Lehman then representative
Edwards thank you Mr chairman So based
on what I'm reading here you had only
one bid is there a reason others didn't
bid I assume you sent out proposals to a
number of area contractors oh no we we
we did the whole process there was a you
know everybody's pre-qualified and the
you know do website and all of that like
like any other project and and some of
that is like the
e911 got five or six bids I forget now
and uh which went to bid at about the
same time um we had I think we had six
companies that were interested in in the
project and and that we thought cuz you
you get a sense of this right they do
walk Etc who might bid and we had six
companies that were interested we we do
follow-ups with people to say why didn't
you bid why did you bid it's a very big
complicated process um you know you can
you can make a you can make a decent
living on doing State work but State
work is often very complicated um and
sometimes the the the more complicated
projects um get fewer biders you know
when we bid the forensic hospital I
think there were two biders for example
and
um I mean we're really happy with that
that hutter bid but we talked to some of
the other ones and and they look at it
and they talk to their subs and they
just kind of go in a different direction
they're like you know what we're going
to bid if I'm honest I think that there
were two or three biders who were
deciding am I going to bid uh YDC or am
I going to bid 911 and they bid 911
instead um hter hutter happened to
actually do both um didn't win that one
did win this one but we're in a climate
where uh everybody's got a lot of work
you know if you're trying to put a porch
on the front of your house you know that
um he said with experience um the uh and
they have a lot of work so they're
choosy and this is big and it's
complicated and and we we push risk onto
the contractor as people know we do
design bid build and you know you bid a
contract at 32 million you're committing
to build it at 32 million and and there
aren't a lot of lot of ways around that
and so you have to assume a lot of RK
and it's a big project and so people
look at it that way thank you uh Mr
chairman I will be voting no along with
Senator U
berdel from the start I've had problems
with this entire project and I just
think it continues so spin out of
control representative Edwards all right
different different topic but kind of
related I've heard the commissioner and
Senator B so uh accurately describe the
shared services uh in in many points
enumerating things like laundry and and
food and and basic Logistics supplies
that sort of thing but there was also
this concept that clinical resources
could be shared or sharable as well by
having kind of a pediatric focus at
Hamstead and sort of a juvenile
pediatric aspect at the YDC there was
certainly the thought that perhaps
clinical staff could be shared as well
particularly in some Edge situations
like uh emergency coverage overnight or
the weekends you know that there's some
way to to handle that and just having
the Synergy of um pediatric clinicians
in Hamstead and at the YDC th I'm I'm
hoping that there's enough clinical
interchange and and exposure to one
another that that it it creates
it creates a real shared environment and
so so I've heard you both dismiss the
clinical aspect of this but I I I would
hope that that wasn't
intentional no I I wasn't intentionally
trying to dismiss that I mean we Ed the
term Children's Center of Excellence for
being able to have a campus where we're
able to provide services in those
facilities and the whole idea would be
economy of scales to be able to use the
resources that we have for either
facility as deemed appropriate
so that wouldn't rule out clinical and I
think the instances you give are good
examples I'm I'm
M Senator
rosenal thank you Mr chairman will you
be able to share Educational Services
potentially we can't mix the two
populations together as they're served
so that doesn't mean that we couldn't
have teachers that teach it both but we
can't mix the populations together in
one
classroom I sorry my question really was
could the same
teachers work at both facilities
potentially yes yes and is that
something you're considering we're
considering everything thank
you including the
walkway forther
discussion virtualization
temporary all right seeing none we have
a motion in a second to adopt FIS
24353 I'm going to ask the clerk to do a
roll call vote on
this the motion is to approve f 24
353 three thank
you here okay starting again
representative Edwards yes represent yes
representative Lehman no
sen wner
yes Senator gray yes Senator Pearl yes
Senator bero No Senator Rosenwald yes
Senator delandro yes I'll try to get
this right representative wner well wer
no
Jesus motion passes and it is adopted
three 7 to three the next one we have
off consent is
24372 I believe that's represented
gray some observations on
that um this one certainly the windfall
needs a discussion and so uh I have made
suggestions to the commissioner uh that
there be some limits put on this um I
suggested that if it was 10 million he
come in for a limit of 15 million or if
it's 50 million he come in for a limit
of 75 million so that there are some
some
boundaries uh that uh if cross would
have to come back to fiscal in next
month which is the last time that we'd
be able to to take this and I'll turn it
over to the commissioner
now yes uh thank you Senator um so this
item is designed and we refer to this as
the waterfall item so this is what we
would um we use lot utilize at the end
of our process to make sure that we are
spending every last scent of the arpa
sfrf funds um and in order to do that we
need to be able to have enough time to
to uh complete the process of all of the
um items that you've discussed here over
the last you know couple couple of years
and most recently over the last two
months as we sort of closed down the
final
reallocations um there's a process that
goes with that so after uh you um um
consider the accept and expend items
those obviously have to go to Executive
Council and then we have to get
contracts in place we have to have
contracts in place in order for those
funds to count as obligated under the
federal deadline so uh we are rushing
and most of my fellow Commissioners
behind me probably are not happy with me
at the moment but we are rushing them to
get these items through uh executive
councel hopefully at their next meeting
but almost exclusively by their November
I believe 14th meeting and the reason
for that is that we do need to cons
continue to have a little bit of wiggle
room because these projects as you hear
uh through the voices of all of us
trying to administer these projects
uh have uh there are no straight lines
it is all very up and down and uh where
we might have uh an amount of money that
that it that um a department may say
they have funds available to put back
effectively into the till you know when
we get two weeks into a a full review of
that with our staff and their staff it
might be a different number and so um
this is designed to
accommodate a little bit of that
ambiguity it that we reach at the end of
this process so what we did with this
item was we effectively recreated the
same uh thing that we did under car's
act which you may recall uh we had a
waterfall item that at that time flowed
into the unemployment insurance trust
fund um this time what we are suggesting
and requesting is that those the the
remaining arpa sfrf funds would flow
into the affordable housing trust fund
at the new at New Hampshire housing so
any funds that would be left unobligated
so without Contra contracted um services
in place uh by the end of this deadline
we would execute an amount uh equal to
that that would go to um the affordable
housing trust fund so that is that's
that's the goal here uh just as a
followup
uh some of the Senators are not
comfortable with a blank checkbook yes
okay are not comfortable with
if a large n amount of money is returned
that all going to housing when in my
opinion uh the uh deferred maintenance
of the state buildings is in terrible
shape uh we could save money you know in
future budgets by not having people in
leased spaces but renovating spaces that
we own uh and so again that's that's why
the concept that that I came up with was
the guard
rails there have been conversations with
me about people who would like to uh
table this item until next month uh but
I don't think that we need to do that I
think that that if you can look into
your crystal ball and say
well you know I'm guessing that the
number would be and we give you a
reasonable amount of money over that
um that we can both go home today and
and and be
happy I'm not a good
guesser if I I could just say one thing
on that I think to your point Senator uh
you know if if there were other projects
conceivably let's say that you know we
have a big contract out there that for
one reason or another isn't able to be
executed and we have to rush something I
mean let's just say that they that
agency holds out you know hope until the
last possible moment so we're talking
sometime in mid December and we have
that project ultimately doesn't come
together um given you know the process
and the procurement and the that that we
would have to undertake to reassign
those funds um put them through this
process put them through executive
counsel it starts to become a real
challenge I I would think and I I I'm
just really very hesitant and super
focused on making sure that we don't end
up in a situation where we don't have an
option and there's like let's say two or
three million dollars left on a table
somewhere um and then ultimately have to
send that back to the federal government
that's and I understand um the the
concern here we we did this under car's
act we've tried to model the same
approach for arpa um and understand that
we will get to a point at the end of
this year when um it it's a number that
I I I I really can't comfortably say in
and put the state in a position if I get
it wrong of having to um pay some money
back to the federal government I
hopefully that's a fair
statement Senator rosenal thank you Mr
chairman what I what I think I've heard
you
say or imply
is that you don't believe there will be
any more time to bring any more arpa fun
items to the November fiscal meeting
so essentially what I think I'm hearing
is you want to nail this down today
without us
knowing how much is in that blank check
or I mean because the way it's
written it just basically says anything
that's unobligated prior to December
31st
2024 which would mean it could come back
next month for a vote but are are you
saying or implying that there will not
be any more arpa fund requests at the
November fiscal meeting because you
don't think there's time to write
contracts so we have to do this today a
couple of things there's a lot there
Senator I think one is I'm not aware of
any U items coming to the November
fiscal from arpa arpa funded projects
there um the the other issue in the
scenario that you raise is that if we
even if we put this off until November
I'm not going to know
what the unobligated amount is because
there still remain Council meetings as
much as we're trying to get all of those
through there are potentially changes
that would occur let's say in December
under either an existing contract or a
contract that is not yet uh been fully
executed that could change and put us in
the position that I've been describing
so I I understand it's a little bit of a
um uh an unknown
I I I I I could I could conceivably
guess that the number would be um
probably well I don't even want to do
that because if one big one goes wrong
then I'm then I've given you the wrong
number so I'm I'm a little bit put in a
tough position understandably here but
at the same time sort of our prime
directive is not send any money back and
anything that ends up um not becoming
obligated under what we've got in front
of you um would end up
um providing more resources to solve the
the housing crisis and it would be for
affordable housing in New Hampshire so
um it's a it's a it's a bit of a
um tough
situation follow up you I remember the
cares act waterfall item and you did
know the number then it was like $50
million um
somewhere in that neighborhood it was
really
big how is it that you knew in
advance that
number but you don't think you're going
to know this number I I I would I would
I would say that we at that time in my
memory of this Senator is that we did
not know the uh the final number we we
were I I vividly remember running
numbers and calculations with the goer
staff on Christmas Eve um on what those
numbers would be as we reach toward the
end of that cares act deadline you might
be recalling that we did have separate
items under cares act under the CRF that
went directly to the uh unemployment
insurance trust fund uh specific
obligations but my memory would be that
we did not know the final water fall
number until we got fre it was right
around Christmas time in of 2000 or
2020 Senator Pearl for a
question thank you
commissioner you know the affordable
housing fund is certainly a uh a a
notable place to put this I guess my
question is it possible that this
waterfall could spill into more than one
pool I mean you can design a waterfall
any any way that you would like I think
we did discuss having some
some multiple places but it just uh it
just amplifies the problem that we're
talking about which is how much is it a
percentage is it an amount like and then
you have to have separate contracts and
um it just seems simpler to say if you
know if we make it if we certainly see
both in my gopher life and my Bea life
that the housing crisis is probably near
the top of the issues and we've tried
and we've invested a good amount of
money of ARA funds into that issue um
that at the very end that would be
probably one of the most effective
places to put that final amount of that
we just don't know what that number is
right now um and and and accomplish an
important goal for the state thank
you further
discussion um s agre if I could get uh
Mr Arling housee up to the the thing cuz
I do want to talk about deferred
maintenance I mean
um we were discussing other things
yesterday and uh I believe that there
are contracts out there that uh arpa
money could be put forward for um and if
those were to come forward next month
then I would be less hesitant to give
you the blank check for the rest of it
if we could make some kind of
Arrangement you know that those those
items would be considered to come
forward for at least part of this money
that would have gone in to the
waterfall so I so desperately want to
figure out a way to say yes to this um
but I let me let me walk through um
because we haven't talked about this the
the challenge
um in in the in the one big the
governor's arpa item that he talked
about about there are two things that
that that are coming to us for for
maintenance type issues and there are
two things the one is the State House
bathrooms I'm going to use that as an
example we have a contract for State
House
bathrooms I have to figure out a way to
amend the contract on some ridiculous
timeline Taylor's giving me um but in a
nice way um and um but what we're going
to do is go Oh wait we're doing
bathrooms we already have a contract to
do bathrooms we're doing this many
bathrooms we're just going to add the
other ones to it okay that works we can
do that that makes sense I have a number
I can negotiate a number we don't have
to do drawings we don't have to do
additional design work so good we're
doing some things with the with the
annex renovation the same way and it's
you got a guy um gutting things for his
bestest he's going to got more things
for his bestest for for a lot of other
things and God knows there's enough I I
said to somebody when they asked our
deferred maintenance list if we really
did one that was accurate would be
something like a billion dollarss um
and um somebody corrected me when I said
that and they said I think we're I think
only between 8 and 900 million but
whatever it is there's there's a lot we
could do um the problem is I would then
have to I'd have to scope the work
design the contract go back and forth
with with the contractor you know called
like Turnstone is doing this go back and
forth with them then get it through doj
then get it to the governor and council
meeting I got an i if they have a second
meeting in December I would have an
outside shot of hitting that if we could
pick a really good
item the the problem is I don't I don't
have a have a a a parking lot a a fund I
mean I have a I have a deferred
maintenance fund right we we have that
in the state it it's not obligated in a
in an arpa pleasing way arpa you have to
have a a contract with a vendor and so I
can't I could probably find a couple
things where we could like like nudge a
contract a little bit for a mill for a
few million here and there but it would
be less about
doing one of the things you said to me
when we talked yesterday that that
struck me is one of the things you're
looking to do is to is to do things that
if we don't do them with arpa funds for
example we would have to do them in the
capital budget or we would have to do
them particularly the operating budget I
I think I would be reduced because of
because of the timing because it's late
October right now um I would be reduced
to doing things that aren't my top
priorities but worth doing or we would
quote unquote buy a building and I'm not
sure anybody really wants to buy any
more buildings I certainly don't does
that make
sense I mean I I I want God knows I want
the money I really do but I I just don't
think I can make it work on the time
it's because we have a 12:31
timetable certainly I understand you
know what you've told me um certainly
that things that I can put money into
for deferred maintenance that doesn't
come out of the general fund is where I
want to go uh but I'm also not
comfortable with an open-ended you know
waterfall that I have no idea whether
it's you know 20 million 100 million 200
million either and so I'm kind of left
between the rocking hard places they say
where I need to support putting that
money somewhere where it's going to be
useful but I've got other places other
than
housing if there is significant money
that I would like to see those things
taken care of
also so I don't disagree Senator and
trust me I I spend more time
unfortunately telling a lot of people
that we may not have resources than I do
telling people that we do that have
requested funds so um there is
definitely that component to it but as
commissioner Arling house points out we
we are at a point in time where it is
really really difficult for us to be
able to move funds um that we're still
not 100% sure that we would have into a
project that then had to go through a
normal process I mean you have one more
meeting in fiscal committee uh we have
just a handful of meetings left under
executive Council all of which we need
to have full approval from um and in the
case of accept an expend request twice
you know once once here and once there
um and uh it just gets to be um a timing
issue as much as anything
else further
discussion the
um I will make a little statement before
I move item uh certainly I would like to
see a commitment anything that we can
move uh if there is additional funds so
that we could make a decision in the
November meeting whether or not that
should go into the wall uh the waterfall
or whether or not it's something that we
would like to do uh certainly this
motion doesn't preclude that um so I as
I said before I think I'm between a rock
and a hard place and I got to support
this item because it needs support uh
but behind the scenes I think there are
things that we can do uh to push things
into that November
meeting um if there is significant money
that that needs to be done so I will
move the
item there a
second who was the second Senator Dallas
Andro motion a second to approve item
243 72 is there any further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no the item is adopted we're moving on
to Tab 8 the regular
calendar and the item is
uh Department of
Transportation these are the the money
for the uh winter maintenance on the
Turn
Pipe any
questions representative lean moves to
approve item
24365 Senator rosenal second is there
any further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I I oppose no the item is
adopted moving on to tab
nine renewable energy
fund item
24351 is there any discussion Senator
rosemal do have a couple of questions hi
Josh
almost good afternoon
Senator always good day Jorge it's good
to see you Senator you know how I love
to talk about energy I do I do so um two
questions if I could Mr
chairman um when that my understanding
is that this item grew out of house bill
1465 um
which um
allowed the fund to be used for the
office of wind industry development and
energy
Innovation at the time the department
testified that they would not need any
more funds so I guess my first question
is you told us in the spring you could
do it within existing budget why can't
you and then I have another question
sure happy to answer that question um
first for the record Josh Elliot
director of the division of policy and
programs with the Department of energy
um as this bill has went made its way
through the process um the original
contemplation was to fund the um a
position that would Encompass all of
these duties um through federal funds um
we have a program called the state
energy program that um essentially it's
a Federal Grant in order to um Most
states use it to provide staff their
their energy
offices um the uh approval of the
original effective date had been pushed
out I believe for two years originally
um and then this idea sort of came
through um uh through the legislature of
okay what if we move these duties within
this existing office and change it from
the office of offshore wind and Industry
to the office of originally the office
of um uh energy Innovation period and
included all these duties but attained
the original duties um based on uh RSA
I'm looking here um RSA 362 F10 Roman
one um allows the agency I'm Sorry by
moving it within um that office uh
allowed it to be then funded out of the
renewable energy fund one of the uses of
the renewable energy fund um there's a
whole series um as know we went through
this in the dedicated funds committee U
meeting earlier this month um includes
this office um with the move of these
duties into the into that office um the
renewable energy fund then became an
option to um fund this position rather
than using um repurposing federal funds
um that um would have uh excuse me
repurchasing federal funds and then
going through the state budget process
in order to um create that position go
through that whole that whole process it
would come before um House and Senate
Finance committees um so given that the
uh legislature moved this into the
renewable energy fund this option
through the statute to come before this
committee um to create and fund that
position was given
instead follow I guess I have two more
questions right so the second one is um
so um RSA
F4 defines what renewable energy is and
nuclear energy whether it's good bad or
indifferent is not included in the
definition of renewable energy
so how does the department
justify funding a
nuclear uh project analyst out of the
renewable energy fund thank you for the
question um so this office of energy
Innovation or offshore wind and Industry
and energy Innovation is sort of more of
a uh all-encompassing sort of office
it's going to be looking at a number of
other things including battery storage
things like that there are green
hydrogen all those sort of innovative
things I'm not going to touch the land
mine as to whether or not nuclear is
renewable depending on who you talk to
there's very strong opinions about that
so um and probably of no consequence to
this committee uh so that being said um
the statute itself um allows the funding
of this entire office and puts those
duties of those of these specific duties
regarding nuclear into that office that
office itself is funded out of the
renewable energy fund so that is that is
the
connection thank you well um maybe some
people think it's renewable but New
Hampshire statutes Say It Isn't So
maybe we need to rethink our statutes if
you want nuclear energy to be CL
classified as renewable but my last
question is what um what kind of budget
for this office is the department going
to come in with for next
budget um that is a good uh that is a
good question I don't have the answer
off the top of my head I can get you the
answer for that um just to give you a
sense um it is an office of uh if this
item was approved it would be an office
of two would be one an office of two
thank you thank you Mr
chairman further discussion on the
item Senator birdell moves to adopt
Senator Pearl
seconds roll call would you like a roll
call on item
351 all right clerk will call a roll on
the adoption of item 24351
straight this
time representative Edwards
yes CL VES yes Representative leean
no Representative walner
no Senator gray
yes Senator Pearl
yes Senator
burdel Senator roswald no Senator
alesandro no representative Wier yes
uh the vote is one two three four five
six to four motion passes item is
adopted we have two late
items excuse me Mr chair um under Tab 10
you have two items that require approval
344 is the release of the treasury's
Audits and 369 being a request by our
office to fill funds fill position all
right we'll move to item
24344 move the item Senator GR moves to
adopt and Senator birdell seconds is
there any further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppos no the item
is
adopted we voted no you just say say no
I'm not voting okay saying if anybody
move item 369 second 24 369 is moved and
seconded there any further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no those items are adopted anything else
before we go to late items no thank you
okay first late
item
from Information Technology we see uh
commissioner gay is here
24373 okay motion by representative lean
to accept the item and second by Senator
delis Sandro is any further discussion
seeing none all in favor say say I I
oppos no that item is
adopted next late item is
24374 Senator birdell moves to adopt
item
24374 Senator birdell seconds it Senator
rosenal can't do the same thing at
once any further discussion on 37 for
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no that item is
adopted next on the item I believe we
have
the report the
analyses colal control review is that
correct are are you going to talk about
there informational items I believe
repres item that anybody has a question
on Senator representative Edwards uh yes
sir I I wanted to mention um the uh the
operating statistics dashboard that is
uh item
345 um the the governor when he was here
earlier and then I think the
commissioner uh both emphasized in their
discussions today the importance of
mission zero and I I don't know who has
the authority to modify the dashboard
report but I think it would be a a good
idea if the department has the authority
to do it on their own
is to create a little visual information
so that uh the legislature and other
stakeholders were able to easily see our
history and progress on complying with
our mission zero objectives so so that's
my request to the department I think if
they have the authority to add that to
the dashboard that they do
that uh Nathan white Chief Financial
Officer thank you representative Edwards
um the the dashboard is uh elective it
is uh done at the will and discretion of
the commissioner it's always been used
as an informational item for the
committee just to provide updates so
there's no statutory or administrative
rule restrictions around what goes in or
what goes out I can take that back I can
talk to the commissioner about it um if
if we do move towards doing that there
will be probably a multi-month delay
because November's fiscal items are
basically due in a couple of days uh
just due to the long process there um
but I will take that back and we will
have discussions to figure out what how
to best represent that information so
appreciate it all right thanks for
considering and educating me about who
has the authority to modify that report
I didn't I didn't know that so so I I I
do think it's such an important topic to
the state uh and to the uh doj even uh
that we we communicate how we're doing
on this really important process thank
you
anything further from the committee
members before we move on to
the
analysis on the judicial
Council seeing
none yes
no we're ready to do the judicial
control of judicial councel
if you ask the chair he may let you sit
in the others yeah seats so you have you
can sit by a mic Nina if you
want good
afternoon good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
I'm Christine Young director of audits
for the LBA uh we're here this afternoon
to present our assessment of the
internal controls in place over the
judicial council's revenues and
expenditures Jim larier senior auditor
with our office senior audit manager
with our office was the in charge on the
audit he will present the report and uh
also joining us from from the judicial
council is executive director Jay Bucky
and Nina Gardner the chair of the
judicial Council and uh they'll be
available for questions so with that I
will turn it over to Jim for the
presentation of the
report good afternoon chairman wer and
members of the committee again for the
record my name is Jim lavier I will be
presenting the report on the results of
our assessment of the internal controls
in place over the receipt deposit
recording and reporting of revenues and
the authorization payment recording and
reporting of expenditures of the
judicial Council during the N9 months
ended March 31st
2024 if you turn to the table of
contents you will see the report
contains 14
observations in looking at the
recommendation summary beginning on page
two you can see the judicial Council
concurred with all observations
observations number one and number seven
identify that legislative action may be
required on page eight in the table the
Jud the judicial Council reported
$185,000 of revenues and $40 million of
expenditures during the 9 months ended
March 31st
2024 the majority of those expenditures
are for contract payments to attorneys
and legal service providers Who provided
Indigent defense for criminal
cases in in the interest of time I'll
get into the findings and
recommendations observation number one
beginning on page 11 we recommend the
judicial Council ensure Indigent
defendants are provided with timely
assistance of council that they review
the structure and Authority for setting
fees for the Indigent defendant councel
and related services
develop policies and procedures for the
periodic formal evaluation of council
fees and ensure that fees and the
delivery of its Indigent defense
delivery system are in compliance with
laws and
rules observation number two on
beginning on page
16 we recommend the council in
consultation with the Department of
Information Technology replace its case
management and billing system with a new
system that is secure and meets its
operational
needs the judicial Council should also
seek the cooperation of the judicial
branch for the elect electronic exchange
of
data the judicial Council provides
funding for the public defender court
appointed special Advocates and legal
assistants in observation number three
beginning on page 17 we recommend the
council improve its oversight and
contract monitoring activities to help
ensure that those funded entities
operate in compliance with
administrative fiscal and other program
requirements and
objectives observation number four on
page 20 recommends the council
strengthen its core Financial Accounting
Resources by establishing a financial
manager position to oversee its daily
Financial
operations observation number five on
page 21 identifies the judicial
council's needs to strengthen controls
in replacing its case management and
billing system with a new system that
could help prevent duplicate payments
from being
made observations number six and number
seven deal with conflicts of interest
observation number six on page 22
recommends the judicial Council
established a policy to address how to
handle conflicts of interest in Rel
related party
transactions the policies and procedures
should require the council members to
properly report actual or perceived
conflicts of interest to maintain the
Public's trust and
confidence observation number seven
recommends the judicial Council ensure
its members file statements of financial
interest in accordance with RSA
15a and that the legislature consider
amending the law to require all members
of the council file a statement of
financial
interests observation number eight
beginning on page 25 identifies the need
for council members to fulfill their St
statutory
obligation if members are unable to fill
fulfill their duties on the council a
replacement should be sought through the
statutory
process observation number nine
beginning on page 26 recommends the
judicial counsil of establish a system
of standard operating policies and
procedures to increase the effectiveness
and efficiencies in the council's role
with regard to the administration of
justice observation number 10 on page 27
recommends the judicial Council
establish and IND document a formal risk
assessment process and regularly review
its financial and operational activities
for indicators of risk exposure and
monitor control controls to address
those
risks observation number 11 on page 28
recommends the judicial Council work
with the Department of Information
Technology to ensure acceptance of its
2027 Information Technology plan and
Implement procedures to comply with the
law observation number 12 beginning on
page 29 recommends the judicial Council
prepare PR Implement and maintain plans
that are fundamental to an effective
system of internal controls including
formal strategic continuity of
operations and Disaster Recovery
plans observation number 13 beginning on
page 30 notes the council does not have
policies and procedures for instances
when contracted attorneys providing
services to Indigent defendants
terminate a case prior to final
disposition position including not
having policies and procedures for
subsequently collecting outstanding
debts from these contracted
attorneys our last observation
observation number 14 on page 32
recommends the judicial Council adhere
to its statutory requirement of
submitting a banal report to the
governor and
councel the appendix beginning on page
33 reports on the current status of
prior audit findings contained in the
judicial council's Financial audit
report for the 9 months end in March
31st
2014 the status key at the bottom of
page 34 shows the judicial Council fully
resolve three observations had one
observation that was in the process of
remediation and three observations that
were
unresolved this concludes my
presentation I'd like to thank Nina
Gardner chair of the judicial Council
Jay Bucky executive director and the
staff of the judicial Council for their
cooperation and assistance throughout
the
audit we're happy to answer any
questions from the committee now or we
could turn it over to the judicial
Council for any comments that they may
have thank you questions from
committee sen Grace uh certainly I'm
interested in
knowing um about uh 20141
20142 those items and I guess it's
20144 and also in the recommendations
where it says judicial action or I
should say legislative action uh who is
going to be responsible for contacting
somebody because the filing period in
the house is almost over but we have one
in November there'll be one in November
so I will be submitting
legislation anybody on the on the
committee wishes to co sponsor I will
put you down as a
co-sponsor
and the status of the ones that weren't
resolved from
yes lucky certainly in addressing in
2014 number one um we are one of the
agencies that has been referenced
earlier today that is scrambling to um
encumber Federal funds uh we secured
funding for a uh database uh replacement
we have um we are working with a vendor
currently and we are hoping to have
those funds encumbered by the end of the
year um we're currently in the process
of Simply going back and forth uh with
the vendor to finalize contract terms so
I'm certainly optimistic that we will
reach the deadline of the end of this
year to encumber those funds and to
reach that Milestone I I agree with the
audit finding that the database
certainly needs to be replaced I think
that replacing the database will yield a
lot of benefits not just for the
judicial Council quite frankly but for
the judicial branch as well I think it's
going to be a real uh cost savings for
both
agencies and two
yes um again we concur with this
recommendation uh currently to to meet
this recommendation what I have set up
with nhpd is to regularize regularize
the uh meetings with them to go over
their
to go over um steps they have taken to
comply with audits they've had done and
just to Simply um set up a regular time
and to document that um to make sure
that it's getting done not simply on an
ad hoc basis but that it's formalized
regularized and that something that we
can come back and show progress on uh at
at our next audit
check-in and item number three at least
you've uh done partial on that but item
four again is there's no dots filled in
on that
correct audit 4 no steps have been taken
on that yet quite frankly uh at least in
my view and I I'm happy to take feedback
I view the other items those are sort of
those are my priorities currently to get
those done as soon as possible because
nhpd is our largest contractor the
database is very time sensitive So
currently my focuses on those two and
then I certainly concur with that
recommendation that that uh RIS risk
assessment needs to be complet as
well and you expect to have those all of
those items uh completed
by I mean it's 10 years now
right correct uh 10 years since the last
audit um I I can only say I I only took
over at this agency in November of last
year um so I can't speak to what
happened before then but um I think I
outlined in my responses the times that
I thought that these various uh
Milestones could be reached and we're
certainly going to work aggressively um
towards meeting all the recommendations
in the audit um and I I should also take
this opportunity to thank the staff of
the LBA Mr La rier um and the time they
spent at our office working with us and
they've been responsive when I've had
questions about how to meet some of
their recommendations they've been
helpful and forthcoming on making those
suggestions and helping us move forward
with meeting those recommendations and
the fiscal committee will expect
progress reports as you complete these
items sir
well certainly that's one of the things
that I've discussed with LBA in the past
on these things is that I don't see a
lot of oversight on audit findings and
how you know in my prior life I would
expect that every audit item would have
a a plan of action Milestone and
Reporting out on delinquencies and all
of that other stuff we don't have that
here in the state I understand that okay
but there ought to be some kind of
review at some point that says you know
I had this audit I've still got these
items uh and nothing has happened or
something has happened since so just a
comment on my end thank
you representative Earth for a motion oh
we don't need to was that was
pre-released oh it's already been made
okay dat of next meeting U Mr Buck Bucky
leave me some contact information so
when I work on the legislation I can be
in touch
certainly believe that the next meeting
has really already been scheduled it has
November
15th any further items to come before us
Mr Kane ask Mr Kane a question Mr Kane
are there any audits expected the next
month that we should pre-release there
may be one but your motion at the last
meeting would take November as well yes
we we already made a motion on the
cafer no that would if there's an
extension or release request uh that
would come at the November meeting so
you should see that on the 15th very
good anything else to come before the
committee we are
adjourned thank you thank you thank you
thank
you um One never loves audits but this
was
lovable I mean you know thank you it's
it's tough to